how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Deadpool 3 is a project that fans
are super excited about we know that
it's going to be a raunchy rated R
comedy thankfully Disney is keeping it
rated R however it looks like Deadpool 3
is actually going to be a lot more
important to the MCU than we thought it
would be as it looks like Deadpool 3 is
going to play a pivotal role in the
start of Avengers Secret Wars and today
we have a new tease from Ryan Reynolds
that lines up with some previous reports
telling us that Deadpool truly is about
to go explore the Multiverse and of
course as we know he's not going to be
doing this alone as Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine will be joining him and will
be with him every step along the way
however it does look like they'll be
taking at least one pit stop at the TVA
the time variance Authority Ryan
Reynolds has recently teased this and
today we'll talk about that teaser and
what to expect from Deadpool 3 that
lines up with some reports that we've
recently heard that have us ask talking
some pretty big questions and tell us
that Deadpool 3 is going to be much more
important than we think so today we'll
go over this teaser and talk about these
questions and how Deadpool 3 will kick
off Secret Wars in a really big way so
yesterday a Miss minutes TVA Twitter
account which is an unofficial account
but a very large account nonetheless
tweeted at Ryan Reynolds actually they
specifically tweeted at the Deadpool
Twitter account simply tweeting hey
there Deadpool love Miss minutes now
this was a little curious considering
the fact that it wasn't an official
account but still curious nonetheless
because there's recently been a report
that Mobius from the TVA is going to be
in Deadpool 3. so of course this sparked
everybody's attention but things got
really interesting last night when Ryan
Reynolds actually replied all he said
was hello Miss minutes kind of giving
fans a little bit of a tease as what's
to come for Deadpool 3 as we know Mobius
is going to be in it of course he'll be
working with the TVA but right now now
the TVA as we know it is controlled by
Kang the Conqueror or at least a variant
of King so now that Ryan Reynolds is
kind of teasing us here with replying to
miss minutes it has us thinking more
about how exactly the TVA is going to be
involved in Deadpool 3. and more
importantly how exactly is Deadpool
going to affect the entire Multiverse
and the TVA itself now going back to the
original report that came out a few
weeks ago stating that Owen Wilson will
be playing a big part in Deadpool 3 not
just a cameo but it's been reported that
he will play a big part and something
you have to keep in mind and remember is
that after the events of Loki after the
final episode when Sylvie killed he who
remained the Mobius we knew essentially
kind of got erased at least temporarily
for the moment so as of right now the
Mobius that we knew might not be the
Mobius that's going to be in Deadpool 3.
however there are some important things
that we do need to talk about concerning
the TVA and concerning the Multiverse
and Kang the reason Deadpool 3 is going
to be so important is that Phase 5
really doesn't have that many projects
that are focused on the Multiverse of
course we have Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania coming out in February this
is actually the next Marvel project that
we're going to get this is obviously
going to dive into who Kang the
Conqueror is and the Multiverse a little
bit but we won't really be visiting
other universes everything's kind of
going to be contained to the quantum
realm the point of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is to reveal Kang the
Conqueror as a big multiversal threat
but again from there we aren't really
going to be diving into other universes
however Loki 2 is going to be coming in
Phase 5 as well and this is where things
are going to get a little bit more clear
and where hopefully and logically we
would dive into other universes but
still it is mostly going to be a story
about Loki Sylvie and Mobius nonetheless
it will be a very serious show that will
set up the future events and then we
have Deadpool 3 kicking off phase six
now phase six is where things are truly
going to get started for Avengers Secret
Wars and it all starts with Deadpool 3.
Deadpool 3 has already been confirmed to
be a multiversal movie Deadpool and Hugh
Jackman are going to be traveling
through the Multiverse going to
different universes until they make
their way to the MCU and clearly the TVA
has caught on to Deadpool and whatever
he's doing and there are some key things
that we need to talk about concerning
Deadpool's multiversal travels one is
how exactly does Deadpool get involved
with the TBA do they manage to capture
him and bring him back to the TVA
headquarters or do they simply keep
trying to capture him in different
universes but he keeps evading them I
think it's pretty easy to imagine the
TVA capturing Deadpool but Deadpool
escaping in fact this could be how
Deadpool kind of starts remember at the
end of Deadpool 2 Ryan Reynolds took
Cable's time travel device and kind of
cleaned up the timeline as he called it
well if we learned anything from the
first season of Loki it's that time
travel is kind of a no-go for the TV ba
and it kind of prompts them to appear
and erase you so this would be a perfect
segue Ryan Reynolds messing with the
timeline in Deadpool 2 for the TVA to
show up and say hey no no come with us
and I actually really like this idea
because again we know Deadpool's going
to be a super funny movie but now it's
also going to be a very serious movie
with big implications for the future of
the MCU so we're kind of getting the
Best of Both Worlds here so Deadpool
could get taken to the TVA in which I
imagine he'll kind of go through the
same thing that Loki went through
watching the Miss Minutes video about
how the Multiverse almost was torn apart
and then instead of the timekeepers
coming and saving the timeline it was
Kang who came and saved the timeline
because remember at the end of Loki it
was no longer the statue of The Three
Time Keepers but a statue of King but
from there I'm imagining that Deadpool's
going to get his hands on a TVA time
door in fact I'm pretty positive he will
steal it from Mobius and this is how
Mobius will get involved I'm sure
everybody could picture this in their
head Deadpool stealing a Time door for
Mobius opening up the portal running
through it and Mobius running after him
and from there Mobius is probably kind
of screwed as Deadpool's not going to
give that device back but is more than
likely going to drag him along the other
option is he simply steals a Time door
device opens up a portal leaves and now
it's mobius's job to track him down
however unlike before where Deadpool
only have the ability to time travel now
Deadpool has the ability to Multiverse
travel and this could be where Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine comes in because
they've already said that they're not
going to undo the events of Logan so
perhaps The Wolverine we see is going to
be taken from Another Universe now we
know that Deadpool is going to cause a
whole bunch of chaos and of course this
is most likely going to mess up some
universes and probably cause at least
some incursions and this kind of fits
into a Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe storyline however of course
it's not going to be the Marvel Universe
but most likely the fox universe and
some other universes involved until he
makes his way to the MCU Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman have basically told us
that this is going to be sort of a road
trip between Deadpool and Wolverine and
that it's kind of going to be a rashamon
style type of deal I've said this
several times but in case you don't know
rashmon was a film about the death of a
samurai told from various people's
perspectives so each person tells the
story and sees it a little bit
differently so what we'll most likely
see here is Deadpool hijacking a Time
door device then hijacking Hugh Jackman
and then the two of them go on a
multiversal road trip causing incursions
which in turn causes a huge problem for
the TVA which causes the TVA to then
chase them until they eventually make
their way to the MCU now rumor has it
not confirmed but rumor has it that the
X-Men are going to be joining Deadpool
in this and Deadpool is indeed going to
be bringing some X-Men into the MCU the
original Fox X-Men this will sort of be
Kevin feige's goodbye to the fox
universe as Kevin feige first started
working with Marvel on the original
X-Men films and and of course Secret
Wars is the perfect opportunity to get
them into our universe and then say bye
afterwards so obviously Deadpool is
going to be causing a lot of chaos here
and I don't think he gets to the MCU
without causing a few incursions and
that's where things get really serious
this is where he'll most likely run into
another Avenger perhaps Doctor Strange
because as we know it's Doctor Strange's
job to kind of monitor all of this
especially after he learned about
incursions in Doctor Strange 2 and this
is where it'll kick off the events of
Secret Wars truly kick them off like I
said we'll have Ant-Man Quantum Mania
and Loki 2 but this is where all of the
other heroes are going to start to get
involved and where incursions become a
very serious Multiverse threatening
problem so as you can see as it looks
like Deadpool 3 is indeed going to be a
very serious movie for the events that
are going to come in Marvel's phase 6.
I'm not expecting Kang to be in Deadpool
3 however I am expecting him to be at
least mentioned and I am very much
looking forward to a sort of road trip
between Deadpool and Wolverine but hey
let me know your thoughts about this and
this Miss minutes tv80 tease in the
comments down below if this is what
Deadpool 3 is going to be like will you
enjoy it be sure to let me know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
thank you